With Fifty Shades Of Grey out now, let’s
take a look at 25 things you probably didn’t
know about the big-screen version of E.L.
James’s erotic novel!
In order to keep the Fifty Shades Of Grey
script top-secret, during early auditions,
actors were asked to prepare a scene from
another film.
Jamie Dornan, who plays Christian Grey, chose
a scene from the 90s movie True Romance, which
was written by Quentin Tarantino.
For her Fifty Shades audition, Dakota Johnson
read a four-page monologue from the 60s psychological
drama Persona, which was written and directed
by Ingmar Bergman.
Johnson’s performance of this particular
piece allowed the filmmakers to see she was
capable of bringing to life Ana’s emotional
journey in Fifty Shades Of Grey.
Jamie Dornan has said the scene he most enjoyed
filming was the first time that Christian
and Ana meet, which the filmmakers shot over
two days.
To help them develop a believable mother-daughter
bond, Dakota Johnson, who plays Ana, and Jennifer
Ehle, who plays Ana’s mother, would chat
on the phone while Johnson was on set and
Ehle was at home.
The actresses found this particularly helpful
as most of Ana and her mother’s communication
takes place over the phone.
Fifty Shades Of Grey was shot in the Canadian
city of Vancouver, which doubled for the book’s
setting in the US cities of Seattle and Vancouver
in Washington State, and Portland, Oregon.
And although the story is set in summer, filming
actually took place in winter.
The filmmakers kept the details of what they
were filming and where as quiet as possible.
They did this to avoid roads and streets becoming
crowded with onlookers which could have led
to expensive delays to their tight production
schedule.
Use of the title Fifty Shades Of Grey was
banned on set and in any correspondence or
printed materials connected with the film.
Instead, the crew used the fake name The Adventure
Of Max And Banks.
Max is the name of EL James’s dog, and Banks
is the name of screenwriter Kelly Marcel’s
puppy.
There were 55 locations in the movie’s final
shooting schedule.
The Fairmont Hotel in Vancouver, Canada, doubled
for the Heathman Hotel in Portland, Oregon,
while the University of British Columbia stood
in for Washington State University.
Ana and Christian’s first date at a coffee
shop was filmed in the Gastown district of
Vancouver, Canada, which doubled for Portland.
Ladner Village Hardware, which is located
in a small town about 45 minutes from Vancouver,
was chosen to represent Clayton’s Hardware
Store, where Ana works while in college.
When production designer David Wasco first
met with director Sam Taylor-Johnson, the
pair discovered they’d each, independently,
chosen the same photograph as a reference
shot for the tone and look of Fifty Shades
Of Grey.
The photograph was by fashion photographer
Helmut Newton, from his book White Women.
Author E.L.
James drew a floor plan of Christian’s penthouse
to help production designer David Wasco get
to grips with the layout of Christian’s
home in the Fifty Shades trilogy.
Two Vancouver houses built a quarter of a
mile apart for entrepreneurial brothers in
the 1920s feature in the film.
To make sure they gave the homes the right
look for the story’s setting, the movie’s
design team researched upper-end Seattle homes.
One of the Vancouver homes was used for the
exterior of Christian’s family residence,
as well as its foyer and dining room.
While the second home was used for its glass-enclosed
swimming pool, which appears instead of the
book’s boathouse.
Sets were built for Christian’s penthouse
including the living room, kitchen, dining
room, his bedroom, Ana’s bedroom, and, of
course, the Red Room.
They concealed the sets by building them on
stages so preventing people from seeing them.
The whole build covered three stages.
To create the look of Christian’s penthouse,
the filmmakers used as a point of reference
the work of architects including Norman Foster,
John Parson, and Hugh Newell Jacobsen.
Thanks to her background as an artist, director
Sam Taylor-Johnson was able to secure paintings
by artists including Ed Ruscha and John Baldessari
to display in the offices of Christian Grey.
The work of many other artists also appears
in the film, as does one of the director’s
own pieces.
The most challenging and revealing scenes
between Christian and Ana were kept till the
end of the shoot.
So, the scenes in Christian’s infamous Red
Room were shot during the last two weeks of
filming.
Dakota Johnson wanted her reaction to the
Red Room to be as genuine as possible, so
the very first time she saw it was when her
character Ana sees it for the first time in
the movie.
To heighten the impact of the Red Room, the
filmmakers limited the use of red and black
in the movie, except for graduation gowns
at Washington State University’s graduation
ceremony.
To make sure they got the look of the Red
Room just right, production designer and set
decorator David and Sandy Wasco consulted
the experts, in other words, dominatrices
with Christian Grey-type clients.
One of the things they discovered was that
leather is the best floor covering because
of all the kneeling people do.
Author E.L.
James was quite specific about the room’s
layout and director Sam Taylor-Johnson was
quite particular about its appearance.
For example, Taylor-Johnson wanted the room
to reference high-end stables, so the design
team went for brown leather and wood equipment
as opposed to the black often favoured in
such rooms.
Much of the furniture and equipment seen in
the Red Room was custom-made in England.
To research his character Christian Grey,
Jamie Dornan visited a sex-dungeon to watch
a session between a dominant and a submissive.
A great deal of care was taken over the design
of Christian Grey’s clothes.
The filmmakers discussed issues such as the
type of cuffs, collars and lapels, the weight
of the fabric, and the amount of patterning.
All but one of the suits worn by Jamie Dornan
were handmade, and all his shirts were also
custom-made.
And if there’d been enough time, his footwear
would also have been bespoke, but all his
shoes were still top-of-the-line.
Costume designer Mark Bridges was very specific
about Christian’s ties, their thickness,
their sturdiness and, of course, how grey
they were!
All of Christian’s infamous silver ties
were specifically designed and painstakingly
handmade.
Costume designer Mark Bridges designed a peach
silk and chiffon dress for Ana which echoes
an iconic dress worn by Faye Dunaway in the
1968 film The Thomas Crown Affair.
Author E.L.
James set a challenge for the movie’s property
master Dan Sissons for the scene where Christian
and Ana share champagne after her graduation.
James showed Sissons a photo of a pair of
antique teacups she owns and asked him if
he could find them or something similar for
the scene.
The cups are actually over one hundred years
old and the company that made them no longer
exists, but Sissons managed to track down
six identical cups, which arrived on set just
48 hours after his conversation with James!
Christian Grey has Audi’s latest fleet of
cars at his disposal including the R8 sports
car, the S8 sedan cruiser, and the brand new
A3, which he gives Ana as a gift.
Although the latest model A3 wasn’t available
to buy until after filming ended, the filmmakers
managed to secure it for their shoot.
Christian’s EC130 helicopter, Charlie Tango,
is the largest helicopter that may be privately
owned and costs around $2 million!
For the movie, the art department fully customised
the EC130 including its graphics so they fit
the designs found elsewhere in Christian’s
professional world.
Sam Taylor-Johnson directed the music video
for “Earned It”, by Canadian singer-songwriter
The Weeknd, which features in Fifty Shades
Of Grey.
The music video features Dakota Johnson and
the work of Fifty Shades Of Grey cinematographer
Seamus McGarvey.
Well there you have it, 25 things you probably
didn't know about Fifty Shades Of Grey!
Now, tell me, what’s your favourite big-screen
adaptation?
If you enjoyed this video, hit the thumbs-up
button and subscribe for more things you didn't
know and weekly movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!